okay all right what are your tips for
auditioning lay on your lines
who's the first person you make friends
with on sets the caterers if you were
stranded on a desert island what film or
television box set would you take with
you I'd like the 24 box set once again
because it was just epic which accent do
you find the easiest or hardest I find
it crazy to do that Irish accent looking
back now what do you see as your big
break mmm I did a studio piece with
theater in Glasgow and Seton's theater
called tomfool and it transferred to
London which then led to me getting
Romeo which then led to me going to the
RSC so that's probably my big break
which part do you wish you'd had the
chance to play or direct I always wanted
to play Leonardo DiCaprio is part in the
beach what's the secret to success I
just don't know okay which superpower
would help you to do your job better a
photographic memory if you could steal
someone else's career who would it be
and why never steal anyone else's career
want your own everything for a reason
who should play the next James Bond
don't know but I'd love to be a Bond
girl if you were stranded on a desert
island what film TV box set or game
would you take with you I've been
playing a lot of cards against humanity'
recently but that's no fun if you're on
your own age 5 what did you want to be
when you grew up
oh I know the answer to this because I
found a letter that I'd written to
myself recently I said that I wanted to
be either an actress or an air
stewardess if it goes wrong you'll find
me serving coffee in the sky do you wish
you'd have the chance to play I want to
play a female Iago
how did you get an agent by writing to
them when I was at drama school and
doing a showcase what's the most devious
thing you've done to get a part or a
film I'm not telling you that that's top
secret
hi I'm a wand rayon and this is my BAFTA
62nd challenge okay which was the most
challenging character you've played
probably the most challenging character
I've played which hasn't been on TV yet
was young Adolf Hitler so I guess you'll
see that soon
what part do you wish you'd had the
chance to play I would have loved to
played either Frodo Baggins or Bilbo
Baggins what are your tips for
auditioning and well I think the first
one is pretty obvious learn your lines
and try and bring it off the page but
don't get too attached to ideas because
they might want you to change what
you're doing if you could work in any
other area of TV what would it be
well that's a good question I think one
day I'd quite like to direct who's the
unsung hero on set I think in Game of
Thrones you've got to give it to Alfie
Allen for putting up with being tortured
for all those years and then going out
and losing in the evening a pool to me
sorry mate all right okay if you were
stranded on a desert island what film
slash TV boxset or games you take with
you at the office what's the most
devious thing you've done to get part
Nev's anything devious Kephart sorry
what new things do you need do your job
empathy patience and an alarm clock
who's the unsung hero on set I would say
the sound Department because the one
thing you don't will do is to go in and
re-record a load of your lines you could
steal someone else's career who would it
be and why little messy I think to be a
footballer we're pretty amazing despite
how much I enjoy acting just grab the
emotions on the last day of shoot and
it's kind of mixed emotions because you
ever since you start a job you look
forward to this or the end of it so that
the stress of actually playing the part
is over but it is very sad to leave four
people working was the one piece of
advice you'd give to a 16 year old self
don't squeeze the spot describe the
emotions on the last ever shoot depends
what the shoots been like sometimes
relief and sometimes sadness
h5 what did you want to be when you grow
up probably if I'm one of your tips for
auditioning be yourself what's the most
devious thing you've done to get a pup I
haven't done anything
devious at all I'm completely honest if
you were standing on desert island what
film TV boxer or game would you take
with you at film send me by tacos be
probably stalker looking back now all
you see is your big break
getting a job in the first place what's
your top tip for learning lines
understand what we're talking about
three things you need to do to do your
job
remember your lines stand in the right
spot and don't fall over the furniture
which party which chance to play
directed it would take too long down to
that one what's your top tip for
learning lines repetition what is the
first thing you do when you come off a
long shoot have a pint of Guinness why
do you make hoody make friends with the
first onset just everybody which
accident you finally easiest honors to
do American times up only answer seven
what's your top tip for auditioning top
tip for listening and learn the lines a
big good start who do you most admire in
your industry who's won most of my on
the industry Edward Norton which film or
TV program has most influenced you film
with TV program probably The Sopranos or
film would be Romeo at that Baz Luhrmann
Romeo and Juliet what three things do
you need to do your what three things do
you need to do your job
clothes
coffee and I can't think of a third
that's probably it okay skip next
question is there a scene you wished
you'd shot and why it wasn't any any
scene it turns up okay well terribly you
answered five questions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]